details have already leaked out about
what James Comey is going to say
tomorrow yeah he's any prepared
statement yeah I prepared Simmons you
read the transi former FBI director
James Comey apparently did not want to
be left alone in a room with Donald
Trump that's what he said yeah which is
why James Comey was just named an
honorary Miss Universe contestant he's
very tall yeah yeah he's very tall what
else is going on a lot of tension
between Trump and his attorney general
that's getting crazy yesterday press
secretary Sean Spicer was asked if the
president has confidence in his attorney
general and he was unable to answer the
question yeah when Spicer was asked if
he had any self-respect left Spicer said
I can't answer that question either I
just want to see my family again
actually it's been reported that
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has
offered to resign yeah president Trump
told him that won't be necessary I'm
taking you down with me
we're gonna go together
yeah there are other things happening
you hear about this a big news from
Canada okay yeah you don't get to hear
that often no slam on Canada it's very
quiet play right right yeah I know
Canadian officials announced they are
planning to build up their military yeah
yeah then then they said that is you
know if it's okay with everybody else
very sweet
crazy story in Utah true story a woman
pulled out two of her son's teeth in a
Walmart bathroom yeah
or is that procedure will soon be known
the Trump care dental plan I don't know
why this dance goes with having to keep
out it just I just did it in
Massachusetts where I'm from in
Massachusetts yes a medical marijuana
dispensary has begun selling marijuana
infused pizza pizza and now when they
combine it to yeah or is that's known
one-stop shopping
[Applause]
it's so clear I don't smoke not because
I don't I really don't it's not a moral
thing it just was never my bag no you
get all your drug information from
dragnet I know I always do a guy who's
high doing this whoo
you